I had there at my house this was like a
year ago and like nine people were there
and the discussion was about in your
lifetime out of all the people you've
ever known what percentage of them ended
up doing what they wanted to do with
their lives Senate which three three
percent and there was one day I was
sitting at my kitchen table with my wife
writing some very big checks to lots of
lawyers and you know and I said if
something doesn't change you know we
could lose everything laziness is
something I really can't tolerate so
because of laziness I think that that
speaks of a sense of entitlement and
that's just not a good look in this
industry for many many years I had told
myself look if things don't work out i
will raise money and i will make an
independent film myself you know if i
have to rob a bank to get the money to
make this movie i hope i can shoot it
before i go to trial and that's the
stipe of stuff i was thinking that was
the hardest moment just because i felt
like if i wasn't the cheerleader anymore
everyone else could potentially walk
away an independent film is a really you
know it's independent film means very
little money it means but very little
money often leads to much more
creativity where does someone go to
figure that out that's interesting movie
sets and just be sort of in the
background no oh you gotta do your own I
mean I just personally believe if you
want to be a film director you need to
just be a film director I've kind of
always had to try to find my own way
that these films made you know I've
always it's always come together in some
really sore strange untraditional way
after like three years or people telling
we know like both my movies have been
that path and one of them is to learn
how to sustain yourself financially how
to make a living in the business and
what it takes to do that and the things
that are most satisfying to your heart
and soul are not the things that are
Jenna
really going to bring you the most money
it's going to be hard if not impossible
to get what you want out of this
business unless you really have the
ability to push through those moments
when it's the hardest thing for you in a
world and you feel like just crushed if
you can push past that I think you have
what it takes to stay in this industry
the other day I was trying to figure out
you know what exactly I do you know and
and I've done like 25 move feature films
you know but if you really analyze what
exactly i do like nine to 10 whatever I
put in 12 hours a day all my life
ninety-nine percent of the time in
spending in trying to make him right
it's not actually making the movie the
actual time that you make the movie when
you're on a set making the movie is like
the vacation nothing was happening and I
wasn't sure what to do and then I saw
I've got to change my life I have to
change I can only change my career if i
change my life there's that expression
go big or go home I think you should go
small or go home on your first project
do something that that is not so
ambitious that you're not going to make
it to the finish line but I realized
that if I do a full time I have to do a
full time and more than full-time you
know what L makers will work in every
hour we can trying to get this this
content made looking good and then
ultimately distributed them and market
is it's a tough thing it's a very tough
sad situation but at the end of the day
you got to do what the hero of a movie
has to do and that is if you want it bad
enough you got to overcome those
deep-seated fears and somehow find the
courage to step up anybody can make a
film now it's like owning a typewriter
of being a novelist you win or write
novels write novels published or not you
want to make films stop worrying about
the festival stop worrying about the
industry worst thing ever for art and
just make movies there's your Gipper
speech
you